ça va regarder qui m'ont appel hugot
clément mon ami que j'aime énormément
qui a fait une émission et collectionne
à lire sur le front qui a très bien
marché et je suis fier de lui et je
laime savamment du coc d'amour temps
facetime sheryfa au bébé regardez comme
il est beau celui-là regardez comme il
est beau savamment hugo avec alex et mm
matin à moi et tu te t'embrasse très
fort alex et la petite mon chéri oh là
là vous êtes trop mignon qu'elle met au
monde hugo dis moi mon chéri toi mine de
rien cette école tout ce qui se passe ou
pas c'est surréaliste on a encore
l'impression de vivre dans un film de
science fiction c'est des trucs qu'on a
vu au ciné qu'on a lues dans les
bouquins mais on pensait pas que ça
arrive par jour et je pense que c'est
dur à beaucoup de gens disent ça il y
aura un avant et un après ce qui est en
train de se passer se pense que les gens
ils ont switché dans leur tête sur la
manière d'aborder la gym c'est ça et que
j'écoute est inquiet toi mon goût pas
franchement oui bien sûr ma santé à moi
mais je suis inquiet pour pour pour tous
les gens l' aléa les chiffres qui
viennent de tomber pour ces dernières 24
heures c'est 89,15 troupe blessés en 24
heures et plus de 900 personnes en
réanimation dont la moitié au moins de
60 ans donc ça touche aussi les
personnes jeunes et ça c'est important
de le rappeler parce qu'on peut se
sentir un peu protégé un peu vulnérable
c'est pas du tout le cas forcément ce
qui inquiète déjà pour les gens qui bat
kim qui meurt et qui vont mourir
malheureusement de cette épidémie est
lui aussi inquiet pour les conséquences
que ça va avoir sur des millions début
aux personnes sur l'économie et on sait
que quand l'économie s'effondre ça aussi
des conséquences
après bien sûr sur la santé des gens sur
la santé physique et mentale des gens
donc voilà je pense que c'est déjà très
compliquée avant cette épidémie c'est
déjà beaucoup de personnes en france et
dans le monde et ça va être encore pire
malheureusement maintenant je vois pas
comment ça ne pourrait ne pas avoir de
conséquence ou ignorés telle urgence
elle rester chez soi tu rates bien que
tu restes chez toi ton nom du bio tu
restes chez toi mais qu'extérieurs
personne et c'est très important de
respecter ça je comprends que ce soit
difficile mais faire confiance aux
médecins ils nous disent que la seule
chose à faire c'est de limiter au
maximum de contacts avec l'extérieur
il faut essayer de le presser de le
faire avec ça c'est très bien alex
metric renversait va très bien passé un
qui s est envolé elle lui les beaux
confinement nîmois et hossa meuf c'est
miss france car elle fait du yoga dans
le salon moi regardions avec gilbert des
débats que de là mais c'est pas vrai le
confinement on n'est pas ce qui m'est
arrivé comme ça et que ça marche chez
tombe atomique mon frère elle fait du
yoga dans ce salon
moi tu avais moi j'ai beau merci gauche
thème fort mon chéri bravo pour ce que
ta peur et tu veux que je serai toujours
là pour te dire tu es une bombe je
t'envoie sport je t'envoie son salut mon
chéri salut alex et sa taille père bien
cette coiffure j'adore bon allez je
t'embrasse fort